Okay.
So I've had a lot of requests for a
video on the North Germanic languages.
So today I present to you a video on
Swedish,
Norwegian,
Danish,
and Finnish.
What?
Hello everyone.
Welcome to the Lange Focus Channel and
my name is Paula.
Today I'm going to talk about the north
Germanic languages of the Nordic nations
that includes the Scandinavian
languages,
Swedish,
Danish,
and Norwegian.
And I will also touch on the languages
of Icelandic and federal wheeze.
I wanted to call this video at the
Scandinavian languages because I just
love the way that word sounds
Scandinavian,
but to the people of that region.
The word Scandinavian only refers to
Denmark,
Sweden,
and Norway,
and not to the other countries that I
want to talk about.
So if I say the Nordic nations,
that also includes Iceland,
the Faroe Islands,
as well as Finland.
I want to talk about the north Germanic
languages spoken in all of those
countries.
So I decided on the title and the North
Germanic languages of the Nordic
nations.
And please note that finish is not in
north dramatic language.
It belongs to a separate language family
entirely.
There are about 20 million native
speakers of North Germanic languages,
and that includes about 9 million
speakers of Swedish,
mainly in Sweden,
but also as a minority language in
Finland.
6 million speakers of Danish,
mainly in Denmark,
but also as a minority language in the
southern less vague region of northern
Germany and in Greenland,
5 million speakers of Norwegian,
mainly in Norway,
320,000
speakers of Icelandic,
mainly in Iceland.
90,000
speakers of feral wheeze.
About two thirds of them living in the
Faroe Islands and the rest of mainly in
Denmark.
The North Germanic languages are,
as you probably guessed,
a branch of the dramatic language
family.
All dramatic language is developed from
Proto Germanic,
which was spoken around 500 bce.
Frodo Germanic possibly originated in
Scandinavia,
and different varieties of dramatic
began to emerge with migration.
Runic inscriptions from the second
century ce show us that by that time,
pro dramatic had began to separate into
distinct western,
eastern and northern dialects.
The northern dialect was spoken in
Scandinavia and is today often referred
to as Prato norse and became the
ancestor of all the north Germanic
languages.
[inaudible] north was spoken from around
the second century Ce to the eighth
century ce and by the beginning of the
Viking era in the eighth century ce,
it had evolved into dialects that are
collectively referred to as old norse.
During the next few hundred years,
vikings seafaring norse people explored
much of Europe by sea and river
conquering lands and establishing
settlements and bringing their language
with them.
During this time,
old north was divided into three
mutually intelligible dialects of old
east,
north,
old west,
north and old goodness.
All these north was spoken in Sweden and
Denmark as well as their overseas
settlements in Russia,
England and in Danish settlements in
Normandy.
Old West North was spoken in Norway as
well as its overseas settlements.
The two most notable where Iceland and
the Faroe Islands,
but also Ireland,
Scotland,
and the isle of Man and Norwegian
settlements in Norman,
deep old goodness was mainly spoken on
the island of Gotland,
which is today part of Sweden as well as
some overseas settlements to the east.
These west East and goodness varieties
of old norse gradually developed into
the modern north Germanic languages.
Around the 14th century CE.
The Western branch of languages consists
of Norwegian,
Icelandic and Pharaoh weeds as well as
some other extinct languages.
The eastern branch consists of Swedish
and Danish.
The goodness branch consists of only the
good initial language,
which is still spoken to some extent on
the island of Gotland,
but these days the north dramatic
languages are generally not thought of
in terms of east,
west and goodness.
They are thought of in terms of
continental and insular.
The continental languages are Danish,
Swedish and Norwegian and the insular
languages.
Our Icelandic and Pharaoh ease.
These categories are based on the mutual
intelligibility of the languages rather
than on the genetic root language that
they come from.
Norwegian is grouped with Swedish and
Danish because even though Icelandic and
Norwegian developed from the same old
west,
North's Norwegian is today much more
intelligible with Swedish and Danish.
One reason for that is the political
union of Denmark and Norway from 1536 to
1814 during this time,
the written Norwegian language stopped
being used and it was replaced by the
written Danish language and this had a
big impact on the spoken dialect of
Norwegian,
especially the central and eastern
dialects.
The continental languages also underwent
a lot of influence from middle,
low German,
which is an influence that didn't effect
Icelandic and fairways.
The three continental languages can be
referred to as the Scandinavian
languages.
When talking about the Scandinavian
languages,
it's important to note that there is a
significant amount of dialectal
variation within each language.
In fact,
the three languages are made up of a
dialect continuum.
That means if you travel in one
direction,
the dialects gradually change the
further you go.
That means,
for example,
that if you are a Norwegian living near
the border with Sweden,
you probably have an easier time
understanding your neighbor just across
the border in Sweden.
Then you do a Norwegian from the other
side of the country.
Even though you are supposedly speaking
a different language from that Swedish
person.
This makes it kind of hard to determine
at what point these dialects become
different languages or if they are in
fact different languages at all.
The three languages are all more or less
intelligible depending on where the
dialect lies on that continuum and the
written languages are almost entirely
intelligible.
Danish seems to be the odd man out with
its complex phonology that has come to
be quite distinct from the written
language.
Swedes and Norwegians often say that
Danish people sound like they're
speaking with a potato in their mouth.
I can't actually confirm if they do
speak with a potato in their mouth,
so scandinavians,
can you let me know if that's true in
the comments down below?
I have Danish roots,
so I'm allowed to make fun of Dan's from
what I understand,
no regions have the easiest time
understanding the other two Scandinavian
languages,
though they understand Swedish better
than Danish.
Swedes can generally understand or
region,
but they have much more trouble
understanding Danish because of its
pronunciation and Danes can more or less
understand Norwegian and to a lesser
extent they can understand some Swedish.
From what I understand,
Scandinavians will generally not speak
the other person's language.
They will speak their own language while
making an effort to understand the other
person's speech and maybe they will slow
down and clarify things when necessary,
but when they have significant trouble
communicating,
they might switch to English,
which isn't that tough for them because
Scandinavians are magical geniuses when
it comes to learning English.
In this kind of situation where you have
three closely related languages that
kind of blend together on a continuum,
the languages are not defined by the
spoken variety but rather by the
official standard language associated
with that country or region.
In Denmark,
there a standard Danish.
In Sweden there is standard Swedish and
in Norway there is standard Norwegian or
wait,
no,
there they're actually two standard
Norwegians.
Okay.
That's right.
Norway actually has two official
standard written languages,
bulk and Nina Osc book model,
which means book language is a Danish
influenced standard language,
which is very close to standard Danish
but which uses Norwegian pronunciation
and knows or new Norwegian is intended
to be a pure version of Norwegian based
on Norway is more conservative Western
dialect.
Okay.
Which Standard Language Norwegians are
educated in,
depends on the region they grow up in.
But despite having two official standard
languages,
Norwegians don't really speak them.
Norwegians generally speak their own
local dialect whenever they are
speaking,
even in formal situations and even when
they're speaking to people from the
other Scandinavian countries.
Because if this Norwegians have to get
used to understanding a wide variety of
spoken dialects and that's probably part
of what makes it easier for them to
understand Swedish and Danish.
But that of course this is just my
speculation.
So native speakers,
you can confirm or disconfirm that.
So let's take a look at the three
continental languages and see just how
similar they are.
Unfortunately,
I wasn't able to find a volunteer to
help me with the Danish sentences.
But let's look at Norwegian and Swedish
and that will give you a general idea of
how similar the continental languages
are.
I love you
y'all.
Ed.
Skip Day ends today.
Okay.
Dogs are the best pets.
Hmm Dad,
Adam Besta who's viewed as the best
shall indeed.
Tomorrow I will go to Germany.
You Marvin sky cutting this clans Emr
Scalia draw to this client.
The party was fun because I liked the
music part.
[inaudible] part is far more so for the
Yeti Tennessee Cam.
Okay.
So you can probably see just how similar
these three languages are and you can
probably see how relatively speaking
they are easy for English speakers to
learn.
They are all category one languages
according to the American Foreign
Service Institute,
which trains for their overseas
assignments.
None of the north dramatic languages are
amongst the most widely spoken languages
in the world.
And people from the Nordic countries
generally speak excellent English.
So is it a waste of time to learn a
north Germanic language?
Of course not.
If you're interested in the cultures and
the history of that region,
then learning one of the languages could
bring you immense joy.
And because the three Scandinavian
languages are so similar,
learning one of them can unlock the
doors to the other ones,
especially of the written languages.
And if you're an avid traveler or you
want to go backpacking around the world,
then you will probably meet a surprising
number of Scandinavians and knowing
their language or even one of the other
two languages will help you break the
ice and get to know some wonderful and
possibly highly attractive people.
And if you are interested in the old
Nordic cultures,
then you might benefit from learning
Icelandic since written Icelandic is
still very similar to old norse,
so don't hesitate to start learning one
of the north Germanic languages,
which could be your portal into a whole
new world itself.
The question of the day,
native speakers of north dramatic
languages,
what does your experience communicating
with the speakers of other languages?
Which of the other languages do you
understand the most and how do you
bridge that communication gap?
We'd like to know and everyone else jump
in and leave whatever comments you want.
Thank you for watching and have a nice,
sure.